what i want to do in this video is
really just expose you and and introduce
you to the idea of even what a a
computer program is and just in case you
want to follow along and i highly
recommend you do that because the real
way to learn computer science is to
really fiddle with things yourself is i
this is a a python environment so i'm
going to be doing a lot of the
programming in python and right here the
environment is called pi scripter
p-y-s-c-r-i-p-t-e-r
it's free it's an open source piece of
software and i'm using python python i
believe i'm using python 2 6 or 2 7 as
long as you're using python 2 you'll
your examples will be the same as mine
they'll work the same way if you use
python 3 you're going to have to use
slightly different variations every now
and then to make it work properly and
i'll try to make notes for those when
when they occur so let's just start
writing ourselves a computer program and
what's cool about this is we can write
our computer program right here and
really we're just editing text in a file
that's all it is it's a set of
instructions and the computer is just
going to start for the most part at the
top of this file and just go down and
read the instructions although you'll
see later on that there's ways to tell
the computer to jump around and loop
around within the instructions so it can
do things over and over again or skip
other things but with that said let's
write ourselves a simple program
and while we do this we'll expose
ourselves to some of the core concepts
that exist within a computer program so
one of the main so let me just write a
very a very very simple computer program
so one very simple computer program
would literally just be an expression so
three
so let me just write print
print three plus seven
so it's literally just going to take
three plus seven and print it it's going
to pass it to the print function which
comes with python and maybe i'll write
it like this print three plus seven and
so let's save this file so there's
literally only if you think about it
only one command here at the top line
says print three plus seven actually
let's add another command just so you
can see that it's going to go from the
top down and let me add another one
print
print two
minus one
and then let's do print
let's do print this is a chunk of text
chunk of text and let's see what this
computer program right here is going to
do
so let me save it
so let me save it i've saved it as the
file test area.py tells the
that's the dot py signifies that it is a
python file and now let me run the
program and what's nice about these
development environments these ide
integrated development environments is
that you can kind of type and run your
programs in the same place it also color
codes your text so you can see what's a
function what's not a function the
different data types and we'll talk more
about data types in the future but let's
just run this program to see what
happens
so there we go we ran it so it printed
10 then it printed one then it printed
this is a chunk of text so it did
exactly what we told it to do and it did
it in the order it started up here it
printed it evaluated 3 plus 7 as equal
to 10 and then it printed it and it
printed 10 here then it printed 2 minus
1. then did that there and then it
printed this is a chunk of text now one
thing i want to introduce you to fairly
early on is the idea of data types so
even when you saw this example you might
have had the gut feeling that look
there's something kind of different
about a three or two or a one or a seven
and this chunk of text this is a number
i can kind of just you know i feel like
i can just kind of add numbers they're
representing they're representing some
type of quantity while this over here is
representing well it's representing a
chunk of text and your intuition would
be right these are different data types
the threes and the sevens and the ones
these are numeric literals and in this
particular case they are integers and
you can and this right over here this is
actually a string which is a word you'll
hear a lot in computer science it's
really referring to a string of
characters and if in python we can
actually ask it what are the types of
these things so you can pass them to the
function type and so
now it should print the type of three
plus seven not just ten so let's try
that and i'll just print two minus one
to just show you the difference and then
i'll i'll print the type
the type of this chunk of text
the type of this chunk of text and so
let's save it
i'll just type control s that's a
shortcut to save this and then i'll try
to run this program
so there you go
it evaluated this statement and to
evaluate this it starts on the inner
parentheses 3 plus 7 is 10 then it tries
to take the type the type of 10 which is
a type int and then it prints that type
int and you see it right here it says
type int int is short for integer
then it says print two minus one it does
that on this line right here prints one
and then it prints the type of this
whole thing right over here so instead
of printing it itself it just printed
its type and its type is a string
now the next thing i want to introduce
you to as we just fiddle our way
experimenting with programs is the idea
of a variable because one of the things
is we're going to want to kind of store
these things in different places and as
we'll learn in future videos in python
it's more of like we want to have labels
on these things and the labels can
change but let's see or we could put
them in different types of labels so
let's write a completely different
program over here and i'll do it using
variables
so let's and what's cool about python or
some people don't like it is you can put
any type of you could put any type of
data in any type of variable so you
could say a
a is equal to three
three plus five
and then we can say b
is equal to
let's say a
times a
a times a
minus
a minus 1
and then you can say c
is equal to
c is equal to
maybe a times b
a times b
and then you could have something like
and then i'll put some space here just
to make it look a little bit just to
make it a little bit cleaner
c is equal to a times b and then we can
say let's print
let's print c
let's print c and so if you want you can
go ahead and try to figure out what c is
going to look like or we could just run
this program so let's run the program
first and then we can go back to see
that it actually did the right thing so
i'm just going to save this program and
now i'm going to run it well i got 444c
so let's see if that makes sense so 3
plus 5 is 8 and it and so the label a
will refer to 8. so any place in the
program until we redefine a anytime you
use a it's it's going to say well a is
an 8 a is referring to 8. so when you go
down over here and we're defining b
it'll say okay a times a it uses order
of operations so in order of operations
you do your multiplication first and so
a times especially when you're comparing
against subtraction so a times a that's
going to be 64 and then we have 64 minus
a so 64 minus 8 is 56
minus 1 is 55. so b is 55 and then c is
going to be a which is 8 times 55 and 8
times 55 is indeed 440.
so it all worked out
and so maybe you want to you you define
these things and you want to see what
happens when you get different a's and
you can try that out you can just change
what happens here for the different a's
so maybe we'll have a is equal to
let's make it equal to
negative 6. now let's run our program
and see what happens
we get negative 246 and you can verify
it for yourself you go line by line and
have these variables refer to what
they're defined to be referring to and
see if you get this response right over
here
now if programs were just a bunch of
commands that you just always go
straight through you wouldn't be able to
do really interesting things and so to
do really interesting things you're
going to start seeing things like
conditionals and loops and a conditional
loop is something like
let's do it like this so
if so i'll just leave that stuff over
there and we'll say if
if a
if a is less than zero
if a is less than zero
maybe we will print
we will print c
and
if
or else
else
print
print let's print otherwise we'll print
c
minus
otherwise we will print c minus a so
this is interesting and you might
already have a gut for what's going to
happen here but let's save it and it's
amazing how much you can get done with
just these conditionals so this is
saying if a is less than 0 do this
otherwise if a is not less than 0 do
this over here so notice we're not just
going to go straight down depending on
whether a is less than zero or not it's
going to either go it's going to either
execute this line or it's going to
execute this line and the way that
python u to only execute this line if a
is less than zero
is it's indented here and in the indent
it's part of this clause and the way it
knows that there are new clauses forming
right here is this colon right over here
and then the way to know what to execute
if if nothing if none of this happens if
or if a is not less than zero it's
within this else clause and if you want
to do something else after this
regardless of whether a is less than 0
or not you just take it out of the
clause by getting rid of the indentation
so now we can just print
we are done
with the program actually let's add some
other stuff in this clause
so
let's print
let's print here a is less than zero so
notice this is not going to be evaluated
we have this inside of a string so it's
just going to print that thing and then
over here we'll say print
print a
is not less than
than
0. so this is an interesting program and
let's let's let's just run it now
all right let's hope it runs
all right so i saved it and now let's
run the program
and it says
it printed a is less than zero so we
could scroll up a little bit
it printed so this is we ran the program
it printed a is less than zero so it
shows that we're inside of this clause
it then it and this is so it printed
this then it printed c which is negative
246
it does not execute this because this
needed to be executed only if a is not
less than zero but then it breaks out of
that clause and it prints this no matter
what we are done with the program and
let's just change a to try to see if we
can get this other clause to print so
let's make a greater than zero so let's
make a equal to nine and now let's run
the program
now let's run the program
and so there a is nine
so it says is a less than zero well nine
isn't less than zero so it's not going
to execute this it's going to go to the
else clause and so it's going to print a
is not less than 0 which it did over
here then it printed c minus a it
printed c minus a which is 630 then it
breaks out of that clause and regardless
of whether a is less than 0 or not it
prints we are done with the program